this is a real story it almost sounds
fake but it's all too real and things
are getting insane
remember that Trump blackmail file which
was researched and assembled by highly
regarded former British intelligence
officer Christopher Steele he didn't do
it alone right and one of the people who
helped him put that file together is
former Russian KGB chief oleg Aero
thinkin and as a reminder this is a
dossier that talks about Trump of being
hiring prostitutes to participate in all
sort of urinary fetish stuff I mean this
entire thing right that Russia has been
cultivating Trump for five years that
there were sweetener business deals
offered to Trump that entire thing this
is almost giving me the chills
this guy was found dead in the back of
his car in Moscow under what are being
called suspicious circumstances
aravindan was a key aide to igor ii a
former deputy prime minister who's named
in this dossier several times
aravindh khun's body was found in a
black Lexus an investigation started
aravindh khun's body was sent to the FSB
morgue
there's been no cause of death confirmed
initially the FBI is investigating later
we heard oh he died of a heart attack
there doesn't really need to be an
investigation and by the way like I told
you a couple of weeks ago Christopher
Steele is still in hiding
following his unmasking is the author of
that trump dossier this is massive and
corporate media is basically silent on
this I mean it's just the next sketchy
chapter in these so far unconfirmed
reports we know that Russia has a
history of going after its political
opponents
well coincident if this guy got in the
way of them having influence over
American politics of course that he was
going to be enemy number one a Russian
spy helps the Brits put together a
dossier about Donald Trump and he's
found dead in the back of his own car in
Russia and we're supposed to believe it
was just a heart attack
you really can't write this stuff I feel
almost like I'm doing Alex Jones
Infowars except this is actually a real
story here very very disturbing